هذا المكان هو المكان الاهم للشعب اسرائيل
واليه يجب ان نعود ونظهر سيادتنا عليه
[موسيقى]
اخبر العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار الجزيره
مرحبا بكم اكثر من 2000 مستوطن يقتحمون
المسجد الاقصى بالتزامن مع احياء ما تسميه
اسرائيل ذكرى خراب الهيكل المستوطن تقدمهم
وزير الامن القومي الذي دعا لما وصفها
بعوده سياده اسرائيل على المسجد في حين
اعنت كتيبه العياش استهداف مستوطنه قرب
جنين بصاروخ من طراز قسام واحد
الجيش النيجيري يعلن تاييده للمجموعه
الانقلابيه التي اطاحت برئيس البلاد ويحذر
من عواقب وقيمه لاي تدخل عسكري والرئيس
يقول انه سيتم انقاذ الديمقراطيه في وقت
توالت فيه الادانه الدوليه وطالبت كل من
الامم المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي وكذلك
الاتحاد الافريقي بالافراج الفوري عن
الرئيس
البنك المركزي والامريكي يرفع اسعار
الفائده بمقدار ربع نقطه مئويه لتبلغ بذلك
اعلى مستوياتها في اثنين وعشرين عاما وهو
ما يرفع سعر الاقراض الاساسي الى خمسه
ونصف في المئه الفيدراليه ارجع ذلك
لاستمرار ارتفاع التضخم كما اشار الى
احتمال رفعه اكثر لاحقا
[موسيقى]
ازمه حرائق الغابات بسبب درجات الحراره
القياسيه تتواصل في دول عده وتتسبب في
تدمير مساحات شاسعه من الغابات الامين
العام للامم المتحده قال ان عصر الاحتباس
الحراري انتهى ووصل عصر الغليان العالمي
والبشر هم المسؤولون عن هذا الوضع الى
اللقاء